[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: This
is from the second book,
but the only spoiler in it
is that my main character is
an astronaut at
this point, which
I trust is not a spoiler
since the title of the series
is the "Lady Astronaut" series.
So, you know-- so
everything is ruined now.
So this is from "The Faded Sky."
And part of the reason that
I'm reading this section is
because it takes place in
the Neutral Buoyancy Lab,
and I actually got to go to the
Neutral Buoyancy Lab and watch
a full dev run--
development run--
with an astronaut.
And the astronaut,
Kjell Lindgren,
said when he was inviting me--
he was like, do you want to--
do you want to come
and watch me do this?
You'll be able to watch
the suit up and everything.
You can hang out all day.
But you probably won't want to
because it'll be really boring.
And I'm like, so,
Kjell, you know how
I'm a professional puppeteer?
Next time you're
in New York, if you
want to go hang out on
Sesame Street, let me know,
but you probably won't
want to hang out all day
because it'll be really boring.
He acknowledged I had a point.
And spoiler, not boring at all.
So I also do the audiobooks.
And what you're
going to see, aside
from the presence of a
microphone and headphones,
is actually the way I
recorded this in the studio.
"The thing about wearing
a space suit on Earth
is that it's designed
for lower gravity.
Even being in the Neutral
Buoyancy Lab's pool
didn't change the fact
that gravity pulled at me.
Sure, it didn't
pull at the suit,
but inside, I slid around every
time I change orientation.
As a woman, I was
smaller than the men
the suits had been
designed for, so I
had to wear padding around my
hips to sort of wedge me in.
This kept the air
bubble surrounding me
inside the suit
distributed evenly,
allowing me to move from
horizontal to vertical
over the course of the NBL
run without fighting gravity.
Without the padding,
the air bubble
acted like a giant beach
ball strapped my stomach,
always wanting to be pointed
up toward the surface.
It made it difficult to
roll in any other direction.
In truth, having an air
bubble inside the suit
wouldn't be a problem
in space, but the NBL
was where people
decided if you had
what it took to do a
spacewalk, so neither I,
nor any of the other
women, would complain.
No, sir.
Everything was splendid, and we
were happy to be in the pool.
I hung sideways in the water
with the fiberglass shell
digging into my armpit.
My neck burned from holding
my head up inside my helmet.
My fingers ached from forcing
my stiff gloves to close
on the edge of the solar panel.
We were practicing repairing.
With the suits pressurized at
4.9 PSI above ambient pressure,
every movement felt like working
against a heavy duty spring.
It wasn't exactly like
working in a vacuum,
but it gave us a sense of
how exhausting it would be.
A wrinkle in my glove felt like
a metal wire across my knuckle,
as the pressure made it rigid.
But if you asked
me how I was doing,
I would be so
very, very chipper.
On the other side of the
panel, Rafael Avelino
swore in Portuguese as his
gloves slid off the wrench.
Our support divers
floated in a pod around us
and let the wrench drift away.
Their job was to keep
us safe, and ours
was to learn how to
do repairs in zero g.
Tethered to the MWS or
'mini-workstation' on the chest
of a spacesuit, the
wrench didn't go far,
but it was still a
pain reeling it in.
As Rafael's curses
buzzed over the comm,
I grinned inside my helmet.
'I'm beginning to understand why
Parker is learning Portuguese.'
On my left and
slightly below me,
Leonard helped me steady
the panel as Rafael
got the wrench back into place.
'We all need more
languages to swear in.
I've just got Latin and Greek,
and there's only so far that
can take you.'
Oh, yeah?
What's a Latin curse like?
Rafael placed the wrench
again and receded his feet
in the foot restraint secured
in a WIF mechanical receptor
on the mock-up
exterior of our craft.
What does WIF stand for?
No idea.
At a certain point, the
acronyms just become the name.
WIF was Widget Interface
Fuggedaboutit."
That's the actual answer that
I got from an actual astronaut
when I asked what that meant.
"One of the many benefits to
building the ships in space
was that we didn't have to
worry about aerodynamics.
Whiffs and grips covered
the surface of the ship.
Rafael's wrench slipped again,
but he didn't lose his grasp.
'Because I could use some
more curses right now.'
Leonard hesitated,
and then, chuckled.
'Actually, most of them aren't
things I can say in mixed
company.'
'Please.' I braced against
my foot restraint as Rafael
finally got the wrench engaged.
'Say the fucking Latin.'
That got a huge
laugh from both men,
though my face flamed
at having said it.
Thank god the helmets meant
they couldn't see me clearly.
Even for a laugh,
that kind of language
was not in my normal vocabulary.
And then, predictably, Jason
Tsao, our Sim Sup du jour,
crackled into our ears.
'Language.' 'Va me, puto,
concacavi me,' Leonard intoned
with great solemnity.
Rafael's head came
up in his helmet.
'Huh.
That is close enough to
Portuguese that I actually
understood it, mostly.'
'Gentlemen.
Lady.'
For a guy from Chicago, Tsao
could be so prim sometimes.
'We have visitors, and
they are listening.'
The three of us exchanged
glances and Rafael
rolled his eyes.
'What language do they speak?'
'English.' Through
the microphone,
we could just make out someone
talking in the background,
but not the substance
of the conversation.
The Sim Sup's response
was sharp and biting.
'No bringing them up
early is absolutely out
of the--' and then
his mic cut off.
What had that been?
Through the water, I couldn't
see what the guys thought,
so I just stood there
bracing the panel.
It wasn't like the Sim Sup
to leave his mic open, which
raised the question of
what sort of visitors
would distract him
that badly, to say
nothing of who might be asking
us to come out of the NBL
early.
Rafael got that bolt tightened
down, and we moved on as a unit
to extend the next
piece of the panel.
This was the fourth time we'd
done this particular NBL run,
and each time, we
got a little faster.
Of course, it
wasn't likely that I
would be the one doing
the EVA, but the IAC
believed in overpreparation.
And after my late start,
I supported them in that.
Besides, it would make being the
IV person, the intravehicular
person, easier if I knew
what they were facing.
Given the communication lags we
would have during the mission,
we couldn't rely
on ground control
to coach the EV team
in every scenario.
'Folks, we're going to stand
down on extending the array.'
The Sim Sup's voice
crackled, then
the microphone
rustled and shifted,
as though he were
handing it off.
We floated underwater with the
constant hum of fans and sound
of our own breath as company.
Then Director Clemons
came on the comm.
'We have to pull
Dr. Flannery out,
but Dr. York and Captain
Avelino will stay and work
through the cleanup.
Dr. Flannery, I need you
out of the pool pronto.'--
Leonard drew a breath as
if he was going to argue,
then snapped his mouth shut so
hard I heard his teeth click.
'Yes, sir.
See you topside.'
I am ashamed to say that
my primary emotion was not
curiosity or even annoyance
that our training had
been interrupted, but relief
that for once, it wasn't me.
Leonard turned from us and
let the divers drag him
through the water
to the platform that
would carry him to the surface.
Rafael and I
floated in the pool.
I let my head slump against
the side of my helmet
and closed my eyes for a
moment while our support
divers reconfigured
the ship mockup
to the end state of the run.
It took so long to
get into the suits
that it made sense to let us
practice the end of the run
while we were
already down there.
I kept listening to the
calm, waiting for Tsao
to tell us something
else about what
was happening with Leonard.
When the divers
were ready for us,
we started the run again,
but kept conversation
to the bare minimum
required for work.
After I got over my relief,
I had a huge case of,
what the devil is going on?
I've been pulled out
of training before,
but not an actual NBL run.
That required restarting
the entire thing, which
was expensive and an enormous
loss of training time.
Heck, the way the
suits were configured,
it took two days just to
replace a crew member.
Short of a medical emergency or
equipment malfunction, nothing
interrupted an NBL run.
So what would Clemons
think was so important
that it couldn't wait, and
why weren't they telling us?
The lift out of the
NBL's pool took ages.
As my helmet breached
the surface of the water,
the stand I was strapped to
supported the 140 kilograms
of my suit.
Trying to walk in a full
suit in Earth's gravity
is not possible.
Even just the bottoms are like--
well, it's like wearing diapers
in a snowsuit made of lead.
The robot in 'Lost in Space'
had more grace than we did.
I hung in the donning stand
as a swarm of suit techs
helped us to disrobe.
When you want
answers, everything
seems to take longer.
I waited for my suit tech to
remove the tools and tethers
and leg weights.
As much as I wanted to
rush her, everything
had to be done in sequence.
On the other side of
the donning stand,
Rafael was going through the
same slow, careful extraction
from his space suit.
It was like my suit tech
was moving underwater
as she opened the
valve on the side
to depressurize the space
suit down to below one.
Sure, I could talk now,
and she could hear me,
along with everyone else
listening on my comms.
My suit tech but her hands
on the release of my gloves.
'Breathe out.' I exhaled as the
remaining bit of delta pressure
popped, released when
she popped the glove.
It wasn't likely that I
would blow out a lung,
but overprecautions were
the IAC's stock and trade.
The suit settled around me
as she pulled the glove away.
Then, finally, she
reached for the helmet.
The moment it was off, I
asked her, what's going on?
She glanced over her
shoulder at the control room.
We were told to get you
cleaned up as fast as possible.
'It's the FBI.'"
[APPLAUSE]
JASON GESSNER: Thanks
for that reading.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Sure.
JASON GESSNER: So one
of the first questions
I want to ask you about,
since this was looking back
at kind of an alternate
history of the space race--
how much research
did you end up doing?
What was your favorite
bit of research?
And was there a piece that
just didn't make the cut?
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Oh.
So researching this was a lot
of reading autobiographies.
I focused mostly on the
Mercury and Apollo era.
And then, also, I looked at the
WASPs, the Women Air Force--
or the Women Air
Service Pilots--
from World War II.
So those were kind of the
primary areas of book research.
The other thing that I
did was that I lined up
some topic experts.
So I had Steven Grenada.
I used him as my science
consultant for the whole thing.
He read the entire book.
He does rocket science.
He does robotics.
He was a chemistry
major at NASA Goddard.
He's done all of that.
Then, I also had a
couple of astronauts--
Kjell Lindgren, who was the
one who invited me to the NBL,
and Cady Coleman, who is
a shuttle era astronaut
and an actual lady astronaut.
She's the one who gave me a
lot of the details about having
to put the padding around
the hips in the NBL,
which is something the
guys don't have to do.
And then, also had people--
like, I had a Judaism consultant
because my main character
is Jewish, and I'm not.
So it was lots of
that sort of reading.
One of the things that I would
say was kind of surprising
was I was aware
of the Mercury 13
and kind of like
very loose-- like,
I think someone has
mentioned something about it
at some point.
But I didn't actually know
really anything about them.
And so the Mercury
13 were women who
were put through the
Mercury testing program
to see how women performed.
And some of the things
that I was surprised by
was that we actually performed
better than the guys.
And there are a couple
of reasons for that.
One is that we
tend to be smaller,
but also, the way our
circulatory system works,
partly because they're
designed for carrying
babies and things like that--
we handle G-Forces
significantly better than men.
The other thing-- and this
was my favorite thing--
was that when they did
the stress testing,
all of the women
performed better
than the men in
the stress testing.
And the one that I
was like, oh, well,
that's why, and the delightful
surprise, was one of them
was a mother of eight.
So I just imagine her getting
into the stress testing
and being like, what?
Oh, there's unexpected
noises going off?
Oh, OK.
I have to do a complex
task while someone
is trying to get my attention?
Whatevs.
Is it nap time now?
I mean-- so I loved that.
And I do-- I mention
her in there.
I wanted to actually get
her in as a major character
and couldn't quite get her in.
And there were
other things that--
like, one of the
things that I really
wanted to get into
the books that I
couldn't find a spot
for it was astronauts
do survival training.
JASON GESSNER: OK.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
So they sent them out,
and they're like, OK, we're
going to drop you in a desert,
or we're going to drop you
in this snowy wasteland.
We'll see you in seven days.
Bye bye.
And couldn't-- just
could not-- work that in.
There was a lot
of training stuff
that was like, oh, I want this.
I want this so bad.
Like, no space in space.
[LAUGH]
JASON GESSNER: For
the Mercury 13--
MARY ROBINETTE
KOWAL: A pity laugh.
JASON GESSNER: For
the Mercury 13,
what was the sort of conclusion
from some of that research?
How did they couch, yeah,
thanks for showing up,
but like, no, thanks.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
So what happened
is they got through
the initial testing.
They were getting ready to
go into the next stage, which
required using some
special equipment at NASA.
And went to NASA, and NASA
went to Lyndon Johnson.
And he said, no, absolutely not.
So he drafted a letter saying,
let's shut this thing down.
He never sent the letter.
What the letter he sent
was, well, of course,
I'll leave it up to you.
And strangely, that meant
that nothing happened.
The requirements, then, for
who could become an astronaut
shifted so that you had to have
right around in this time--
and I'm sure it's
completely coincidental--
that shifted so you had
to have so many hours
as a pilot in command of
a jet, which was something
that only people in the military
fighter pilots could have.
So it goes on to have--
they go on to have
congressional hearings.
Like, they fought
this to continue
the training and the testing.
And they go to
congressional hearings.
And the congressional hearings
are basically lots of things
like, men go into space.
Women take care of the home.
And other things
like, well, you know,
of course we'd take any woman
who met the qualifications.
JASON GESSNER: That we just
very carefully crafted.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Right.
Right.
So lots of things like that.
And one of the things,
actually, that also came up
in those hearings was--
so John Glenn was there,
and one of the women
was like, you know,
but you wouldn't
have qualified with the
standards that they have now.
Because when he qualified,
when they put him--
their first orbit.
Their first man really--
Shepard was the first up, but
Glenn was the first to orbit.
When you did that, they
didn't have the requirement
for advanced degrees.
And he got an
advanced degree later,
but he wouldn't have qualified.
And they're like, well, you did.
Why not look at
equivalent things?
And the other thing was
that most of the women
had more flight time than
any of the astronauts
did before they went in
because the air service--
the WASPs were
flying constantly.
A lot of them--
I think all of the Mercury 13
had over 1,000 hours of flight
time clocked.
They were very
impressive pilots.
JASON GESSNER: So let's take
a step back for a second.
So we read that
section of the book.
Could you just talk a
little bit about why
you chose the particular point
in time to start the series,
and what were some of the
decisions around that?
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Right.
So the series starts in
1952 when I slam a meteor
into the Chesapeake Bay.
This is not a spoiler.
I literally do this on the
first line of the novel.
And that's my cusp point.
There is actually
technically a cusp point
before that, which is that I
have Dewey as the president,
because I needed the space
program to be slightly more
advanced.
The reason I chose the 1950s
is that this was a point
at which computers were women.
If you said computer, you
meant someone who did math.
And mechanical computers
were not really--
I mean, they existed,
but they were definitely
far from reliable.
So if you wanted a computer
in space, at that point,
it had to be a woman.
And what I was
looking at, basically,
was what are the
things that would
make people change their mind
about sending women into space?
Having a task that was
defined in that era
as a woman's job, which was
computing, that was one thing.
Making it an
extinction level event
so that we had to be
talking about colonies.
And again, one of
the conversations
they have in the book is, if
you want a colony, you kind of--
there's this component
that you need there
that guys don't have.
Maybe you want to send some--
JASON GESSNER: One time colony.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
You know, just--
but mostly, it was
because of the computing.
JASON GESSNER: OK.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: I needed
technology to be at a point
at which we had the
ability to go into space,
but before we had
mechanical computers.
And 1952 also--
there's a short story
that comes before the novels
that no one in the universe
of the novels is aware of.
And for that, there
needed to be a plot point
that it revolved around
leap year and miscalculating
something based on leap day,
which no one in their universe
knows about.
So that's why it's 1952
specifically, and March 3rd.
JASON GESSNER: OK.
Yeah.
I mean, the events of the
book take place in an arrow
that a lot of us are
familiar with, right?
And one thing as a reader--
it is a sci-fi series,
but at the same time,
you don't have to spend
a lot of time explaining
magical infinite power
sources or faster than light
travel or other nonsense, right?
How did you make
choices about what
to go into detail on on
the sort of hard sci-fi
side versus the story
elements or the characters?
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: I
am very sneaky about this.
So I am--
I was an art major in college.
I'm a professional puppeteer.
I read books out loud for
a living and write things.
Math is a magic system,
as far as I'm concerned.
It's like people can do
amazing things with math,
and I understand that
intellectually, and bully
for them.
So I treated it
like a magic system.
One of the things that I did
was to set up the rules very
clearly and to establish
my character's competence
right at the beginning.
There is a scene very early
on in which Elma is trying
to calculate the size of
the meteor because it's gone
into the Chesapeake Bay-- try
to figure out how big it was
because she's trying to prove
that the Russians could not
have moved it and
aimed it at the--
because it is Cold War.
JASON GESSNER: Right.
Of course.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: So she's
trying to demonstrate this.
And Stephen Grenade gave
me this very long email
in which he walked me
through how this equation--
I found the equation.
I can tell that this
equation does this thing.
But I don't understand any of
the things that are actually
happening here.
So he did the math,
walked me through it.
And then, I just gave
that to my characters,
and there's a conversation
where they're throwing
technical terms at each other.
And you know how when
you're working on something,
and you'll just be like, so--
and then, number of jules--
and you just say
occasional words out loud?
So I have my characters
do that, which
makes them sound super smart.
And all of the math that
they're saying out loud
is correct, right?
And then, later, I can
get away with saying,
and then, I did
the calculations.
And people are like,
oh, she totally no
the calculations are, obviously.
So I would explain it enough
to establish competence.
And then, the only other
times that I would explain it
is if it was something
that you needed
to know in order to understand
something further down
the line.
So the NBL scene is
basically establishing
competence in space.
JASON GESSNER: Right.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
And also giving me the--
it's like, this is what a
WIF is, so that later, when
the WIF is important, I
don't have to stop and say,
while this incredibly
tense scene is happening,
a WIF, by the way, is a
widget interface-- no.
JASON GESSNER: Right.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: I
can't remove what it actually
does stand for.
He did tell me later, but
he had to go look it up.
JASON GESSNER: The first
answer is pretty good.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: It is.
Widget interface.
I told him.
I was like, you know that's
going directly in the book.
He's like, abort, abort.
I'm like--
JASON GESSNER: Too late.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: In.
JASON GESSNER: Yeah.
Well, I like that in the
book, a lot of that does
feel very natural,
and it is introduced
when it helps the story.
And yeah, it's not--
there's no sort of long
winded section about,
oh, let me geek out on
this particular detail.
As a reader, I could tell
you did a lot of fun research
around that, but it also
fits so well into the story
and what the characters are
up to at any given point.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Awesome.
Thank you.
So I find that is
very much about focus,
just providing it
when the character is
thinking about it naturally.
JASON GESSNER: Yeah.
So let's go back and
forward a little bit.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: All right.
I'm excited.
JASON GESSNER: So is it
correct that "The Lady
Astronaut of Mars" was the first
piece you did in this world?
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: No.
JASON GESSNER: Oh, OK.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: It's the
one that I won the Hugo for.
JASON GESSNER: OK.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
The first piece
that I wrote in this
world is a story
that's called "We
Interrupt This Broadcast."
And this is the one that I said
that no one in this universe
knows.
And I wrote something that I
jokingly called my punch card
punk universe.
And the story is basically
a computer engineer
who has decided that society
is going nowhere good
and that it needs a hard
reset, and the meteor
is actually aimed and targeted.
But he dies in the blast,
so no one in this timeline
knows it ever.
It's never going
to be a plot point.
No one will ever know it.
As far as everyone in this
universe is concerned,
it was an act of God.
But that's the first
thing that I wrote.
And then, "Lady Astronaut of
Mars" is the second thing.
And for that, I--
and that's what
prompted these books.
So I knew that she
had this story,
but that story itself
came up because I needed
to write something for an audio
anthology called RIP-OFF, where
we took a famous first line.
And I took the first
line of "Wizard of Oz,"
and then, wrote this story.
Honestly, the reason I said
it's in the punch card punk
universe for that one was
that I had a deadline,
and I had this universe
already created.
JASON GESSNER:
That's a good choice.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
So I was like, why
do this additional work
when this is just here?
And also, I like it.
Like, I like the idea of what
we were able to do in that era.
The fact that my cell phone has
more computing power than we
had in the entire planet, and
we sent people to the moon
in basically these Jiffy Pop
containers, it's amazing.
And all of the calculations
were done with people just doing
calculations.
So anyway, that's--
I don't think that
answered your question.
JASON GESSNER: No, no, no.
That was good.
I clearly have to go back
and read the other piece,
because I have not
read that one yet.
One of the things I love about
"The Lady Astronaut Mars" story
is it feels very much
like it could be kind of,
in some ways, a lost chapter
of "The Martian Chronicles"
or something.
Has that same vibe.
You bring some
Bradbury in later.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Yeah.
JASON GESSNER: And, you know,
me, as a fan of that stuff,
I was very excited about that.
But also, it sets up this really
rich world with so little.
Like, it is a very
short story, and it
has a really, really
powerful arc to it,
but it also is not
heavy on detail.
Like, it sets up just
enough so that you
can connect the dots and
kind of know how we got there
or how those
characters got there.
But then, also, when the first
novel came out, knowing that.
Since that is set farther in
the future than the first novel,
I instantly cared a lot
about those characters, too.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Yeah.
I'm so glad that you felt the
Bradbury vibe, because that
was actually a very--
I thought of it as my homage to
Bradbury when I was writing it.
I want "The Martian Chronicles,"
but with more women.
JASON GESSNER: Solid choice.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Yeah.
Yeah.
And basically, the novels
are I would like "The Martian
Chronicles," but with more women
and people of color, please.
Just not all white
dudes all the time.
But one of the things that was
interesting about coming back
to write this original
was figuring out--
there's a 40 year
gap between them,
so trying to figure out who
Elma was, who Nathaniel was.
One of the things
that I knew going back
was that I wanted
their relationship
to always be rock solid.
I did not want the
marriage to ever
be in jeopardy, partly because
I hate that trope a lot.
The oh no, we fight.
We're going to break up.
No, no, we're deeply
in love again.
I'm like, well, that's
not predictable.
So I didn't want to do that.
So I thought about
those things and kind
of how she would get
there over that time.
And also, how do you become
the lady astronaut of Mars?
Like, how does that
become your name?
What happened?
JASON GESSNER: As a moniker,
it's a solid moniker.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: It is.
It's pretty good.
JASON GESSNER: Yeah.
It was also fun in the books
to see a really exciting,
solid married couple, as
well, and there's a lot
of fun in that relationship.
Yeah.
As a longtime married person, I
was like, oh yeah, that's good.
Anyway, so you have also
written-- so you're not
exclusively a sci-fi writer.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Correct.
JASON GESSNER: You've written
in several different styles
and genres.
How do you think about
what story is right?
Or do you start with
your story idea?
Do you start with a setting?
Like, could you just talk a
little bit about your process
there?
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Yeah.
So it varies from
story to story.
Sometimes, I'll come into
it, and I know the world,
and I know the setting, and
I have to find the character.
Sometimes, I know
the character, and I
need to figure out
the world around them,
or I just like a scene that
I know that I want to write.
And so, then, it's finding
the other pieces of it.
A lot of times, we
liken this to gardening.
But in terms of whether
I do science fiction
or fantasy, these are, for me--
I think of them very
much as set dressing.
So there are some
stories that have
a specific inherent structure.
Like, heist stories have a
specific inherent structure.
Romances have a specific
inherent structure.
But science fiction, fantasy,
these are the set dressing.
This is the layer that goes
on top of that structure.
Because you can have a
science fiction story
that is a hardcore
romance, and you can also
have one that's a heist novel.
Same with fantasy.
So what I tend to do is I think
about the interstitial layers,
the connective tissue.
Because what I find
both things do,
the science fiction
and the fantasy,
is they allow me to
take the natural world,
tip it to the side so I can
see all that connective tissue.
And then, it also allows
me to explore things
that I am thinking about
from the real world,
and it allows me to talk
about them without all
of the emotional baggage.
So I can approach them much more
as a thought experiment, which
then also allows my readers to
engage with it more naturally.
So what I look for then is
kind of what scenic design is
going to support that.
It's very much the same
process I go through when
I'm designing a show.
It's like, what is the aesthetic
that is going to serve this?
Is this a story that's going
to be served by something
that's darker and grittier?
Is this a story that
mechanics are going to serve?
Do I feel like I really
need communication
to be a difficult thing?
In which case, fantasy is going
to work for me much better
than science fiction.
All of the things, I'm
like, why don't you
just call them on a cell phone?
The difficulty and
disabling cell phones
and removing communication,
that is one of the number
one problems with writing
science fiction today.
It's like, why
are you just not--
JASON GESSNER:
Instantaneous communication.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Yeah.
It's always like having to
put people in Faraday boxes.
So I look at that kind of thing.
JASON GESSNER: OK.
So "Calculating
Stars" and "Fated Sky"
are the two most recent novels.
We were talking
about it earlier.
You didn't intend it to be
two novels originally, right?
MARY ROBINETTE
KOWAL: I did not, no.
My plan with this was to write
a single novel, which I had just
titled "The Lady
Astronaut Book."
Had no idea what it
was going to-- there
was a point where it
was "Artemis One."
Like, ridiculous.
I went through 20
titles for this.
I'm not kidding.
But what happened
was that my idea had
been that I was going to
structure it as three novellas
because "The Lady Astronaut
of Mars" was a novella,
and I was like, I'll structure
it as three linked novellas
to mimic the structure of
"Lady Astronaut of Mars."
And part one of
"Calculating Stars"
is that first novella,
more or less untouched.
And I had finished part two
and was starting part three,
and it just felt awful.
And what I realized
was happening
was that I was having
to skip emotional beats
in the second novella in order
to save them for the third one
so I didn't have
repetition points.
And the other thing was that
people read short fiction
for a different thing
than they read novels for.
People read short fiction for
kind of a swift emotional punch
to the gut, and people
read novels for immersion.
And structuring it
as three novellas--
if I had actually published them
as three independent novellas,
I think it would have been fine.
I think it would have been
able to hit all of the things
I wanted to hit.
But because it
was in novel form,
I was having to skip the
immersion aspect of it,
and this is not going to be
satisfying for a novel reader,
reading these back
to back like this.
So I went to my
editor, and I'm like--
so I said all of those things.
And they were
great, and they let
me split it into
two books, which
allowed me to unpack
everything so that part two is
significantly more robust.
I was able to do a lot
more of the training stuff
that I was going to have to--
that in the original one,
I had to skip, and then, could
really unpack the third one
to include a lot
of, again, training
and some additional things
that otherwise, I just
would have had to skip in
order to have that quick in you
would have four a novella.
JASON GESSNER: OK.
And you've had some
exciting news recently
on the new book's front, right?
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Yes.
JASON GESSNER: So we have
more "Lady Astronaut" books.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Yes.
We just sold three
new novels to tour.
JASON GESSNER: Congratulations.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
Thank you very much.
And it's a six figure deal,
which I'm extremely excited by.
Thank you.
It's my first.
It's very exciting.
And thank you.
Thank you for the sympathy
clap there, as I do humble
brags up here.
JASON GESSNER: Feel free.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Thank you.
I appreciate it.
For those of you who watch "Good
Place," I am totally Tahani.
Oh, fork yeah.
So the first book--
or I should say the third book--
is called "The Relentless Moon."
That'll come out in 2020.
I have to turn it in June, which
I'm exhilarated and terrified
by.
But that one is a parallel novel
to "The Faded Sky," so it's
taking place while everybody--
"The Faded Sky"--
again, I don't feel
like this is a spoiler,
if you look at the cover
and you know that the books
are coming from a series that
began with "The Lady
Astronaut of Mars,"
the fact that they
are going to Mars.
And it's a red cover
of someone standing
on the surface of Mars.
I feel like-- surprise.
JASON GESSNER: It's
a safe spoiler.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
Safe bet there.
Anyway, this takes place while
the first Mars expedition
is going on.
And it focuses on Nicole
Wargin and Myrtle Lindholm,
who are two of the
side characters
in the first and second book.
And then, basically,
it's like, hello.
We are on the moon, and we're
trying to establish life here,
and bridge parties are difficult
because gravity is so low.
And oh no, sabotage.
So it's much more in the--
it's going to have
a little bit more
of a thriller vein that
some of the other ones.
And then, in 2021, we have
a non "Lady Astronaut"
book, which is "The Spare
Man," which is basically--
if anyone seen "The
Thin Man" movies,
it's basically "The
Thin Man" in space.
It's an interstellar
cruise ship.
It's a locked room
murder mystery.
Happily married couple
and their dog, Astra.
Thank you.
Someone has watched "The Thin
Man" movies and knows Latin.
And then, in 2022, which does
not sound like a real date
at all, we will have "The
Derivative Base," which
picks up after the
close of "Fated Sky,"
and it's Elma and
Nathaniel again.
JASON GESSNER: Awesome.
Yeah.
Congrats again.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Thanks.
JASON GESSNER: That's big news.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
I'm super excited by it.
JASON GESSNER: Yeah.
So I want to talk a little bit
about some of the other stuff
around being an
author now, right?
So people probably
still have some notion
of the author as like, you
know, locked in a writing
cabin in the woods somewhere.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
That's not inaccurate.
JASON GESSNER: But you
as a modern author,
and especially in
popular fiction,
have a lot of
interaction with people,
probably partly as an
obligation and partly for fun.
Could you talk a little bit
about how you balance that out?
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Yeah.
So one of the interesting
things about being an author
is that the interaction
with the public
has always been
part of the game.
The reason that Charles
Dickens became so popular
and Mark Twain was
actually because they did
public readings all the time.
So that was a lot of what
drove their fame and fortune.
So that audience engagement
kind of is always there.
It's just so much
easier now, and harder,
all at the same time.
So I spend a surprising amount
of time on the road, things
that they don't
tell you when you
sign these standard rich
and famous contracts,
that you are going
to have to be--
thank you for the people
who watch "The Muppets."
So you kind of
travel all the time.
Like right now, I have
been home for two weeks.
Before that, I had been
on the road for 20 days.
I had been home for
a day before that.
And then, two weeks prior
to that, three days home.
And this year has just
kind of been like that.
And it is partly my own fault
because I will say, yes,
I'd love to come do that thing.
Also partly because I have a
couple of different careers
running in tandem.
The thing that's nice about
it is that you actually
can have a career without
doing that, in theory,
through the internet,
which is both good and bad.
When I go to an event,
the people who attend--
there's a certain
buy in that they
have to do to just show up.
So everybody that
I'm interacting with
is generally very pleasant.
I've had the occasional
stalker, but not terrible
compared to some friends.
On the internet, I will have
trolls come at me for reasons.
And as far as I can tell,
it's just because they
felt like it that day.
JASON GESSNER: Sure.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
And it is interesting,
trying to do that balancing
act of wanting to be present
and wanting to engage,
and also, needing
to preserve aspects of self.
So the thing that I talk
about is that mostly
what I think about it is it's
not that I put on a persona,
but that I decide which
parts of my life are public
and which parts of
my life are private.
Like, I rarely talk
about my family.
And one of the things--
when I do, it's always
just bragging about them.
One of the things we were
talking about at lunch
was that I had shingles
during this 20 days of travel,
and I did not want to talk
about it because as soon
as you talk about anything
health related on the internet,
everyone will give you advice.
Like, everyone.
I have a hangnail.
Well, have you tried--
I think at this
point in my life,
I know how to deal
with a hangnail.
JASON GESSNER: You seem
like a sensible adult.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
You know, I try.
But I also had to cancel things.
And I didn't want
to just be like,
oh, I'm just canceling things.
And I didn't want people to
go, she's canceling things.
Is she dying?
Because they will
also go there because,
in fairness, that has happened.
So unfortunately-- so trying to
decide how much to talk about.
So I'll tell people,
I had shingles.
I do not talk about--
actually, no.
In the blog post, I did talk
about the degree of pain
that I was in.
But I talked about-- what I
tried to do was talk about it
in terms of here's a
learning experience for you.
The show does not have to go on.
Don't use my
puppeteer's work ethic.
Take care of yourself.
Be healthy.
So it's learning to couch
things and shift them
so that I maintain control
of the conversation, which
I'm very grateful for having
years of theater before.
Like, I learned all of this
from dealing with third graders.
JASON GESSNER: Excellent.
So you're-- there's a lot of--
looking back at the events
of the past in the most
recent novels with a modern
lens and from the perspective
of people struggling
through that era,
how has the reception
been to that,
or has that sort of like
attracted some of the more
unsavory fan elements?
Because you are criticizing
some of their golden ideas
or whatever nonsense
is coming up.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Yeah.
The thing that-- like, when
people complain about these
books--
for the most part, it has
been very, very positive.
I have to say, really
super positive.
And one of the things--
I do deal with
sexism and racism.
I deal with mental
health issues.
But at the same time, I
feel like it's not so much--
in my head, I'm writing a
book about these things.
I'm not.
I'm writing a book
about space, but I'm not
ignoring those things.
And because so many
books do ignore them,
I think that's what makes it
feel like they're very, very
present.
These are things that
affect the way characters
move through the
world, and so I'm
letting it affect the way
they move through the world,
but I'm not--
for the most part, they aren't--
there's like one or two places
where it's a plot point,
but for the most
part, it's like, this
is the way they move
through the world.
Sexism is a plot point
for Elma because it's
a plot point for me.
When I was vice president
of SFWA, Science Fiction
and Fantasy Writers of America,
and John Scalzi was president,
I got the hate mail.
He didn't.
It's not that he
didn't get any, but I
would get the majority of it.
So it just affects the way
you move through the world.
So I was dealing
with those things.
So when people
complain about it,
what they complain
about is, oh, she's
shoehorning in
these social issues.
I'm like, no, really not.
That's just daily life.
That's the complaint
that I'll get.
The other one that I'll get
is Elma, the main character,
has social anxiety disorder.
So she's in a plane,
and it's going down,
and she's totally fine.
You ask her to speak
to a roomful of people,
and she's like, nuh--
I clearly do not have
social anxiety disorder.
JASON GESSNER: Theater.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Theater.
Although, there are a lot
of people in theater who do.
But what I would get-- the
other pushback that I'll get
is, I don't believe that someone
gets this upset about talking
to people.
Like, no one gets
that upset about it.
I'm like, yeah, actually.
And what I have found is that
people with anxiety disorders
are the best people in crises
because they're like, what,
stress hormones?
Come on.
Bring it.
I got this.
Totally.
That's my daily life.
JASON GESSNER: So I
have one more question,
and then, I think we've
got time for Q&A. Sort
of on that topic of working
through a challenge, earlier,
we were also talking
about how you
approach writing
as sort of a craft,
as well as a creative endeavor.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Right.
JASON GESSNER: Could
you talk a little bit
about how you view that and how
it related to any of your work?
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Sure.
So because I come
at it from theater,
where you couldn't wait
for the muse to arrive,
it's like if I'm
creating something
if, I'm designing
something, I have
to be able to
produce on a deadline
because I put other
people's schedule behind.
It's not a good team
player thing to do.
So I had to learn to
be creative on demand.
And I also have depression.
So one of the things
that I've learned
is that I can work
through a depression,
but it's incredibly difficult.
And the whole creator
as the depressed genius,
it's like I just--
every time that one
comes up, I get stabby.
Because what happens for me
is that my productivity just
crashes and burns.
And I mentioned briefly at
lunch "Forest of Memory,"
which is a novella
that was on tor.com.
I wrote that during the
worst depressive episode
that I've had.
My grandmother had died.
My cat had died unexpectedly
right after that.
Multiple deaths right in a row,
a whole bunch of other things,
chemical imbalance, all of that.
And upon realizing finally
what was happening to me--
this was the episode that
finally made me admit it,
that I had depression
and had it all my life.
In the middle of
that, I was trying
to drop everything, and
there this one anthology,
"METAtropolis: Cascadia."
And my friend, Jay
Lake, was the editor.
And it was the second book
in a shared world anthology,
so replacing me was already
going to be difficult.
And Jay was in the process
of dying from colon cancer.
He was terminal.
There was no way I was
going to back out of this.
Really, this was not something
I could do to my friend.
So that meant that I
just had to write it.
And I crafted my way
through that story.
And people read
it, and they can't
tell, at the end of the day,
because I understand my craft,
because I understand audience,
storytelling, structure.
But I wrote that--
there were some days
that I wrote it,
I could only write
three sentences.
That was my bargain with myself.
I'm like, three sentences.
You can do three
sentences a day.
And there's some days
where I would catch fire,
and I could go longer,
and other days where
I would write three sentences.
And there are a couple of days
where the three sentences were,
I hate everything.
I'm tired.
I'm going to bed.
But I sat down,
and I wrote them.
And for me, this is important
because I can write that way,
but I don't enjoy it.
And my feeling now is if I am
not writing and not loving it,
like if I am dealing with
depression, unless there
is a really serious reason that
I need to push through that,
it is better for me
to take care of myself
and to go and do self care,
and then, come back to it when
there's still joy there.
Because honestly, we
don't get paid enough
to write when it's not fun,
even with a six figure deal.
It's spread out
over multiple years.
But it is good to
know that I can,
that the time that I've
put in learning my craft
allows me to actually
do this thing.
So it is kind of both.
It's like one of
the things that I
try to pay attention to when
I start bogging down is like,
am I bogging down
because there's
a problem with the story,
or am I bogging down
because of something external?
And you handled those
in different ways.
JASON GESSNER: Sure.
Well, great.
Thank you.
So first off, let's give a round
of applause for Mary Robinette.
Thank you.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Thank you.
JASON GESSNER: So we
have a mic over here,
so we have time for questions.
We've got, like, 14, 13 minutes.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: And
I will answer questions
about anything.
So if you want to know--
we didn't talk about puppetry.
If you want to know
about puppetry,
if you want to know
about Regency underwear,
if you want to know about
going to NASA and the NBL,
if you want to know about trying
on a space helmet, anything.
I'll talk about depression.
Anything.
I will also just sit here
and stare at you awkwardly.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to hear about
more than a dozen typewriters.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Ah, yes.
More than a dozen typewriters.
So we have 19
manual typewriters.
First of all, I do not recommend
that you collect typewriters.
They are heavy.
When you move, they
are very heavy.
All of your friends hate
you if you have those.
But our earliest typewriter
is a Blickensderfer, which
is a typewriter from 1890--
I think ours is
1893 model, or 1894.
But it has a rotary head, and
it's not a QWERTY keyboard.
And the cool thing
about the rotary head
is you remember
the IBM Selectrics?
This predates an IBM
Selectric by 70 years
and has a rotary head.
You can replace it to
change the type font.
Really, really cool.
My favorite is the
Corona number 3,
which was the typewriter
that Hemingway took--
I don't have his.
That would be awesome.
It's the typewriter
that he used when
he was doing war reporting
in the First World War.
And it's a folding typewriter,
so it's this tiny thing.
It's like about
that big footprint.
Weighs about three pounds.
There's an aluminum one
that's just stupidly light.
And then, the top
flips back and forth.
I have the Corona number 3
Special, which is forest green.
It's beautiful.
And it has the extended
keyboard that has
mathematical functions on it.
It's very cool.
I will not give you a rundown
of all of the typewriters,
probably.
JASON GESSNER: Does having 19
of them help you write faster?
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
You know, it is--
no.
But I will actually
bring out the typewriter
to write sometimes
because it changes
the rhythms with
which you write,
and there are times
when just changing
the medium of communication is
enough to shake a story idea
loose or you want that rhythm.
Because with a
manual typewriter,
because you have to
hit the carriage return
at the end of each
line, there's a moment
where you're doing
a little composition
at the end of each line.
And then, when you have
to change the paper,
there's another
moment of composition.
So it does completely
change the way I write.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I saw you at the
American Writers Museum.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm pretty sure
you gave this anecdote
from your research
where you found out
that the voice for a computer in
"Star Trek" is really modeled--
that was really
surprising to me,
but it actually makes sense.
Can you say more
about that and what
you learned when you found
that bit of information?
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: All right.
Some of this is
me extrapolating,
so let's be clear.
So one of the interesting
things about computer voices
in the United States is that
they tend, by and large,
to be women.
And we know that the
people with Siri and Alexa
and these other
things, the people
have said very specifically
that they were thinking
about the computer
on "Star Trek"
when they assigned
the female voice
and when they were
thinking about it.
What's interesting is that "Star
Trek," California, JPL, Jet
Propulsion Laboratory-- so
if you're doing research
on space travel,
JPL is the closest
place that you're going to be
able to go when "Star Trek" was
coming out.
JPL had a policy
that the only people
they hired for the computer
department were women.
They did not hire
men as a policy,
and from early, early days.
So the computer voices--
so that means that you've
got this roomful of men
at a launch, and
someone will say,
computer, give us the velocity.
And this one lone woman's
voice will come out and answer.
When you look at Germany,
their computer voices
tend to be male.
When you look at their
early space program,
their computers
tended to be men.
Now, I don't know
that there is--
I mean, I have correlation,
which is not the same as
causation, but there
certainly seems
to be a pattern
there where it looks
very much like art imitating
life, imitating art again.
So I find this back and
forth really fascinating.
AUDIENCE: So I have a daughter,
who I stole this scarf from,
that I was telling you about,
and she's in a Girl Scout
group that's focused--
they're doing this Lego robotics
focused on space exploration.
And I would love to
hear your thoughts
on a topic that would be--
as you did all
this research, what
would be an interesting topic
that, especially a group
of girls in kind of
those dynamics with all
those challenges
that were there early
on-- what would be an
interesting topic for them
to pick as a research project?
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
So it's interesting.
One of the things
that you make me
think about when you ask that
is that when I was researching
this, I watched a number
of episodes of "Mr. Wizard"
from the 1950s.
And then, I also
wound up watching
some of the reboot, the
later reboot from the 70s,
and there was one
in the 80s, as well.
And the interesting thing is
that the one in the 80s, all
of the science that
they're having the girls do
is very gendered.
It's like, let's see about
the science of lipstick.
I'm not kidding.
I don't think that
was "Mr. Wizard,"
but I have actually seen the
science of lipstick, and again,
very stabby.
The 1950s one is
not gendered at all.
The little girls are in skirts,
absolutely, but they're like,
let's look at thermodynamics.
Let's look at how
we create batteries.
He speaks to them and
addresses them exactly
as he would little boys.
So in terms of spaceflight, I
think space is a great topic.
In terms of something that
is specifically about women,
one of the things
that I would say
is have them look at the
early aviation pioneers.
Her name is not in
my head right now,
but does anyone want to make
a guess about what year--
so first of all, the first
professional aeronaut, and that
should give you a
clue right there.
The first professional
aeronaut was a woman.
Does anyone want to guess
about what year this was?
1811.
Right?
This woman was employed by
Napoleon for her ballooning
skills.
So I would say--
I wish I could
remember her name.
I would also say look
at Bessie Coleman.
Bessie Coleman was the first
African-American woman pilot.
It was not legal for her to be
a pilot in the United States.
She couldn't get a license.
And this is in, I want
to say, 1911, 1912.
Very, very early.
So the only place she could get
a license to fly was in Paris.
So she taught herself
French, went to France,
got the pilot's
license, came back.
So looking at the
early pioneers--
I think that they are the ones
who often are most written out
of history because we've had
the most time to write them out
of history.
So I would look at those.
There's a great book
called "Black Wings," which
is about African-American
aviation, that
talks about Bessie Coleman.
I would also say
"Promise to the Moon,"
which is the story of
the Mercury 13 women.
There's a good
documentary about them.
So mercury 13 is also--
what would space look
like if that program
hadn't been shut down?
I think about this all the time.
AUDIENCE: I'm interested in
kind of like the release timing
between "Calculating Sky" and--
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
"Calculating Stars"
and "Fated Sky."
AUDIENCE: "Calculating
Stars" and "Fated Sky,"
which were only three months
apart in release dates.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
Not even three months.
AUDIENCE: My wife just
read Maureen Johnson's most
recent book, only to discover
that it's really half a book,
and that the rest
of the thriller
is still not yet to be released.
What was your sort
of thought process
behind let's get that
out in this time frame
and not wait six
months or whatever?
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
So "Calculating Stars"
came out July 3rd.
"Fated Sky" came out August
21st, which is very fast.
My basic thought process on
that was that my publisher said,
would you like to do this thing?
And I said, yes, I would
like to do that thing.
The reason that this is an
interesting publishing strategy
to try when you have an author
who can turn two books out
that fast--
I wrote the second
book in six months,
which is very fast for
hard science fiction.
The reason is because
there is a known phenomenon
that when the first book
in a series comes out,
there's a bump.
There's something we call
the series death spiral.
So the fifth book in my
series did not sell as well as
the first book by a lot.
But the moment I have a book
come out in a new series,
there's a bump,
and we know that.
So you want you want
new books coming out.
And then we also know that a
lot of people are completists.
They will wait until an
entire series is finished
before they buy any of them.
And then, when the
last book comes out,
there's a bump in the
sales of the first book.
So if you can get both
of them coming out
within about a
month of each other,
you have both of those phenomena
happening at the same time,
and the book sells
significantly better.
So that's basically--
that was the experiment
that they wanted to try.
And it has worked.
Like, when I look at the
diagram of my book sales,
it's like, these books
are doing very nicely.
And then, "Calculating Stars"
happens, and it's way up here.
So it definitely worked.
There's also a number
of other things
that are happening with
"Calculating Stars"--
bringing out a space
book the same year
as the 60th anniversary of
NASA and, the year before,
the 50th anniversary of Apollo.
There's a lot of--
the timing is good.
I hit "Zeitgeist," as well.
But that's why they
wanted to bring them out
back to back like that.
JASON GESSNER: And
as a reader, it
was so exciting to get to the
end of the first book and go,
oh, I only have to wait
a short amount of time.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL: Yeah.
Yeah.
The other thing that
we did not think
through when I said,
yes, that sounds great
was that it meant that I had to
do all that promotion, as well.
Because usually, you promote the
first book for about two weeks
before it comes out.
Then, there's another two
weeks of rah, rah, new book.
When they're coming
out back to back,
it's just basically
like just promotion
all the time, which
was, I mean, fun.
It's a good problem to have.
But, whoa, was not expecting it.
JASON GESSNER: Sure.
Well, thanks again for coming
out and for the reading
and for adding us to
your promotional docket.
MARY ROBINETTE KOWAL:
Thank you for being
in the city I live in.
JASON GESSNER: Yeah.
Happy to.
Well, great.
Thanks a lot.
Mary Robinette.
[APPLAUSE]